these are images of venezuela's security
forces in the neighborhood of la vega in
caracas
they're part of a unit known as faiz a
special action force created in 2016
to fight against crime in the south
american nation
human rights groups say during an
operation here in january
at least 23 people were killed most of
them were
young and poor men father alfredo
infante says
most of the killings were extrajudicial
executions
most of those killed had no links to
gangs or the police that are the ones
who were confronting each other
the victims were not hit by stray
bullets so far nobody has come here to
investigate what happened
father infante says protests had been on
the rise in the area prior to the raid
due to lack of basic services
we have problems with gas water and food
and people take to the streets
curiously after those protests there was
this huge raid that paralyzed people
it was an occupation
the united nations and human rights
organizations claim
the fires have turned into death squads
that have killed
thousands of people in the country over
the past years
they say there is a pattern among those
killed
most of the victims are young and poor
if you live in a poor area and you have
been to jail
it is a death sentence when the police
have a profile on the computer and the
person has a record in 95
of the cases that person is killed
so far this year human rights groups say
over 200 people have been killed by
security forces
venezuela's former prosecutor luis
ortega told al jazeera
nicolas maduro will be investigated at
the international criminal court for the
deaths
of at least 8 thousand people at the
hands of the country's security forces
the investigation includes abuses during
the protests against the government
but also the ones that happened during
raids in poor areas
one of the great confrontations i had
with the government of nicolas maduro is
because of human rights abuses
several massacres at the hands of
security forces i went to the
international
criminal court to denounce the killing
of 8 000 venezuelans
during a period of three years
we are waiting for the beginning of the
investigation against maduro and
generals for human rights abuses
there is no control in venezuela and
there are no investigations into abuses
abuses which the relatives of those
killed have been denouncing for years
with the hope their demands for justice
will finally be heard
al jazeera